- Hello, Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk
about the seven steps
that you can take now
to get wealthy in 2017.
(electronic music)
Alright, so it's the end of the year.
It's a great time to reflect
on the year that's been.
See if you hit your goals or not,
see if you are where
you want to be or not,
and start planning for 2017
to make it the best year
you've ever had.
So, today I'm going to
share the seven steps
you could take right now
to get wealthy in 2017.
Step number one is have a goal,
and that's going to be
probably the most common
bit of advice you get
when you're trying to figure out
what your plan should be for 2017,
and planning for the year ahead,
and I think it's important that
you don't just set another
goal that doesn't happen.
You don't just set a wish, right?
You set something that I think
that I can get this done.
You set a goal that is motivating,
that you look at and say I
would love to have that happen,
and that feels like not just realistic.
Don't just play small.
Don't just say, hey, I did 25k this year,
I want to do 30k next year.
Think about I'm going to work really hard
to go out and achieve this thing,
and it's something that
truly comes from you.
Not because you listened to me,
not because you put on
a Tony Robbins tape.
I remember listening to Tony
Robbins, and I love Tony,
and he was talking write down your goals.
Like, if you want to make a
sculpture, write that down.
You want to do a
painting, write that down.
You want to have a
manuscript, write that down.
Oh yeah, I want to do that, too.
I love that.
I want to have a painting
because I was so caught up
in Tony's energy and enthusiasm
and it wasn't actually
what I wanted to do.
Get excited by the thing
that's on that piece of paper
that I want to go out
and make this happen,
and the more specific it is,
the more it's not just I want
to feel happy about my life,
something specific,
then the easier it is
to go out and attain.
So, set your goals.
Number two is create a better environment,
and this one is so, so, so, so important.
Create a better environment.
Chances are the reasons why you
didn't accomplish your goals
from last year was because
your environment sucks.
Because you have the goals that
make you want to go up here,
but your environment
pulls you right back down
to where you are.
Your friends, your family,
your habits, your routine,
all of that stuff keeps you where you are.
And so, when you think of that bold goal
that you want to go out
and reach for next year
think about what kind of environment
you need to have around you now.
Who are the people that you
need to have around you?
What do you need to have
in your physical space
wherever you're working in
your office, in your home?
What's on the wall?
What music are you listening to?
What videos are you watching?
What books are you reading?
You need to create an environment
that sets you up for success daily.
Every single day.
I don't know about you guys,
but for me I can be so fired up.
I'm fired up today.
It's coming across, and then tomorrow,
I'll be on fire the rest of the day.
I'll be creating amazing
things for you guys,
pumping out more belief into the world,
and tomorrow I'm going to
wake up, it'll be gone.
I'll wake up.
Oh, okay, what do I do?
And I have my schedule,
but what I do in my routines every day
gets me back up to a
high as soon as possible.
So, I wake up, I go to the bathroom,
and then I start putting on some music,
music to change my
state, to get me pumping,
to get me moving, to get me
feeling a little bit of action.
Then, I'll go work out and
I'll be watching videos.
I'll watch the videos to feed my brain,
to not just give me the knowledge,
but also give me the
motivation, the inspiration.
Seeing somebody hit it hard
makes me want to hit it harder.
Hit it harder in the workout,
and then hit it harder when I finish,
and start doing my work for the day.
And so it's so, so, so,
so, so, so, so important
that when you set that
big goal for yourself
that's inspiring and motivating
you then think about
what's the environment
that I need around me to
be able to hit that goal,
and then how can you get
started immediately on it.
Whether that's changing your friends,
putting something on the wall,
listen to music and adjust.
Try things right now.
Don't wait 'til 2017.
Try things right now and
see do I get that feeling.
Think about when you've been
most motivated in your life.
What happened?
Were you at a seminar?
Were you watching a video?
Was there a song playing?
When do you get pumped up and
inspired and feel unstoppable?
What happened just before
you felt unstoppable?
What was the stimulus?
And then instead of randomly
waiting for that to happen,
inject that with intention
every day into your life.
So, whatever that is
do it as one of the first
things you do every single day
so you get hit like,
I'm going to go do this today
and I believe in myself.
I'm going to go attack that big goal.
'Cause if you have a big goal
and you don't have the
environment to support you,
goals never going to happen.
So, create a great environment.
Number three is say yes
to the uncomfortable.
I want you to get used
to being uncomfortable.
When somebody asks you to do things,
when you get an idea that's something
you've never done before,
when you see an
opportunity in front of you
that might be scary, say yes.
Just get used to doing
something uncomfortable.
I've told the story before
of how I wear different color socks.
I actually have them on now.
I have two of them on now.
Let's see, can I get
the foot up high enough?
Can I get the foot up high enough?
Can I?
I can't get the foot up high enough.
I'm going to take off my shoes.
One, two, three.
No, didn't happen.
I got to go further back.
One, two, three.
Get used to doing things
that make you uncomfortable.
Yeah, maybe there's people
behind me watching, right?
But I wear different color socks a lot.
I took it from my son.
He does it all the time.
The first time I tried
doing it was because
I thought of it because Hayden does it.
Then the initial thought that came up was
well, what if people
judge me for doing it?
What if people thing
I'm crazy for doing it?
Then I had to do it, right?
As soon as you worry about
somebody else judging you,
get used to going out and doing it.
Feed off of that discomfort
because it builds the muscle,
then it allows you to challenge
more conventional thinking.
It allows you to push
harder towards your goals.
If it's something that might
cause physical harm maybe,
but a lot of the time the
things that you don't do
because you're afraid of doing it
are things that as you push through them
gives you the confidence
and strength and courage
to go after, push more, and
push more, and push more.
Get used to doing things that
make you feel uncomfortable,
and whenever you get an idea,
this is important you start right now.
Start right now.
Whenever you get an idea of
something that you feel like
you would love to try to do
and you get that voice
inside your head that says,
Oh, you can't do that
because of, whatever,
somebody else's judgment,
as soon as you get that feeling
get used to stomping that out
and forcing yourself to go and do it,
and you'll care less and
less and less and less
about the opinions of others
and you'll listen to yourself
more and more and more and more,
and that is the habit
that will lead to a lot of wealth for you,
a lot of success for you,
a lot of impact for
you in 2017 and beyond.
Alright, the number four step
that you can take right now
to start getting wealthy in 2017
is build in some accountability.
When you are accountable to somebody else
you're much more likely to follow through.
I would try to find somebody
that you can connect with,
whether it's one friend,
whether it's a mastermind group,
whether it's an online group,
whether it's saying things publicly
to your Facebook friends,
or YouTube channel,
or whatever it is.
Build in accountability
so that something happens
if you don't follow through.
If you say you're going to
do this and then you don't,
as an entrepreneur,
who cares?
Right?
You're used to letting yourself down.
You let yourself down all the time,
and it's really hard to
hold yourself accountable.
The best entrepreneurs
do that to themselves.
They have so high standards
that they hold themselves
accountable all the time
and are pushing to do more.
But to build that muscle
build in some accountability for yourself.
Get some people around you.
Talk to your best friend and say,
hey, here's a goal that I want to have.
Can we meet once a week
for a quick phone call
or for a coffee, and I'm
happy to help push you
whatever you want to do.
If you want to lose
weight and go to the gym
you're much more likely to follow through
when you have a friend coming with you.
Apply that to the rest of your goals.
Have a buddy, an entrepreneur
buddy or somebody else.
One of your friends are
trying to accomplish something
in their life.
Great.
Connect weekly and push each other,
because when you commit to somebody else
you're much more likely to follow through,
and I want you to follow
through on your goals.
I want you to stop letting yourself down.
I want this year, when you set that goal,
that you actually go out and hit it,
and a great way to do it is to
build in some accountability.
OK, number five is talk with customers.
At the end of the day, if
you want to get wealthy
it's going to come from
providing a lot of value.
It's going to come from
talking to customers,
understanding what they need.
So, whatever you're creating
you want to talk with your end consumer
and understand what makes them tick.
What problems do they have?
How can you help them?
If you want to make a lot of money
you need to provide a lot of value.
You want to make a lot of money quickly?
Provide a lot of value quickly.
And you get to understand
what kind of value is created
when you understand your customers better
and the problems they have.
I would be setting up as
many meetings as I could
with my customers.
If you haven't started your business yet,
with potential customers,
to understand what's
going through their head.
What problems do they have?
How can I help?
How can I make something
that will be super valuable for you?
Stop just thinking about
things and planning things
and thinking that that's a great idea
and start talking to people
who will actually pay you
and pay attention to you,
and consume the thing
that you're going to make.
Talk with them more.
Set up those meetings now so
you can have a wealthy 2017.
Step number six is create, create, create.
You need to be prolific in your creation.
You need to create every day.
You need to be creating
content, product, services,
whatever it is.
For me it's videos, right?
We're making YouTube videos.
We're putting out three
YouTube videos at least
every single day.
I'm prolific in my creation.
If you look at the people
who are the greatest
at what they do, they practice.
They work.
They create.
So, yes, you may need to consume, right?
At the start of my day, I'm a consumer
at the start of every single day.
I'm watching videos,
I'm listening to music.
I'm consuming that stuff
to get my mindset right
so that I can create.
I made video not that long ago
about how I don't want you to
watch every one of my videos.
I don't want you to
watch every single video.
I want you to watch the video
that applies most to you,
that the title sounds interesting,
the thumbnail brought you in,
and then use the knowledge
and apply it to your business.
Take some action.
I want you to take action.
I'd much rather have you
watch one video a month
that speaks to you and then
you go out and do something
than just consume.
That's YouTube's goal is
they want you on YouTube
as long as possible.
If you could spend 24
hours a day on YouTube,
YouTube would be so happy.
That's not my goal.
I want you out making something.
And so, it's so easy to consume.
Yes, you need to read books.
Yes, you need to watch videos.
Yes, you need to listen to music.
Yes, you need to have conversations.
Yes, you need to go to
seminars and conferences.
Whatever it is, however you get off,
however you consume information,
you need to consume, but
you need to create more.
And the most successful
people are the ones
who start to tip that scale
from consuming so much
and creating a little bit
to consuming a little
bit and creating a lot.
So, I want you to start now.
Get into the habit of creating,
because through the process of creating
you'll discover what
you're really good at.
You'll discover what you could
be the best in the world at.
You'll discover how to bring
your artistic talent through
into creating something
massively valuable.
You'll discover how to test
a whole bunch of different things
and see which is the one
that you want to stick with.
Instead of trying one thing out
you're trying a hundred different things.
You have the time to reallocate to do it.
You're testing out what
works with customers.
You're getting feedback from them.
You're building confidence in yourself.
I can yell at a camera because
I've done 4,000 videos.
Watch my first ones and I sucked,
and I was nervous and scared.
Still the same content,
but my delivery was not great.
And by doing them again, and
again, and again, and again,
by creating more, and
more, and more, and more,
you get better.
You can provide more value,
and you can have more wealth in 2017.
So, yes, you need to consume,
but create, create, create.
Right now.
And number seven, the number seven step
you could take right now
to get wealthy in 2017,
number seven for me is
to find your one word.
It's back there.
I wrote a book about it.
I think self-awareness is
one of the biggest things
that holds people back.
Finding your one word
is about finding the biggest
core value that you have,
understanding who you are as a human being
and then bringing that to your
life and to your business.
For example, if your one word is honesty
then you need to bring more
honesty to your business.
If you are a real estate
agent, as an example,
a lot of people don't
like real estate agents.
A lot of people think real
estate agents aren't very honest.
Great.
Be the honest real estate
agent, whatever that means.
What does honesty mean to you,
and bring that to your business
so you have something that you stand for.
I would love to work with
the honest real estate agent.
I think I have a pretty good one,
but I would love to work with
the honest real estate agent,
or the honest programmer, or
the honest graphic designer,
or whatever it is.
You will attract like-minded people to you
who will love working with you.
The guy who doesn't care about honesty
will be a terrible client for you.
I don't care about honesty,
just give me the work.
That's a terrible client.
He's going to be the most
difficult to come to work with.
He's going to pay you the least.
He's never going to refer you clients.
He's going to give you grief
all through the process
because your values don't align.
And so when you figure out your one word
and then you bring that to your business,
it allows people to find you
because now you're standing for something
that they can self-identify with.
Where if I look at your website
it's probably super boring.
It probably looks like
everybody else in your industry.
There's no way to tell what you do
and how you're really that
different than everybody else
'cause you're all saying the same stuff.
So why am I going to pick you?
Maybe because I found your business card
or something like that, but
why am I going to pick you?
Give me a reason to pick you.
Don't be so boring.
Inject more of your
personality, your value,
into your business.
Where somebody looks at
your website and says
you are the honest programmer.
A lot of people will look at that and say
that's the stupidest thing I've ever seen.
Amazing.
You will never work
well with those people.
Let them self-eliminate.
Where a lot of people look at
that and say that's awesome.
Amazing.
I want to work with that person.
And now you're not just another programmer
out of 100 programmers that
are applying for this position
or being contacted or being
searched for to get that job,
to win that contract, to get that client.
You are clearly off in your own world
and people will self-eliminate
if they don't fit,
and they'll push towards you if they do,
and that's exactly what you want.
So, that's my take.
That's what I think about
the seven steps you can take
right now to get wealthy in 2017.
I'd love to know what do you guys think?
What was your favorite rule?
What do you agree with?
What don't you agree with?
What do you want to add?
What would your eight, nine, ten be?
Did I miss something?
Do you want to add something to the list
that I didn't include?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, have an amazing 2017,
and I'll see you soon.